let's bring in our panel early fox news
senior political analyst brit hume
former education secretary bill bennett
and harold ford jr former tennessee
congressman and ceo of empowerment
inclusion capital gentlemen thanks for
being here britt i want to start with
you that line from secretary blinken in
this hearing that we inherited a
deadline but we did not inherit a plan
your thoughts on that
well first of all
i'm sure there wasn't any kind of of a
plan
but the truth of the matter was there
was no meaningful deadline and the proof
of that is that the deadline such as it
was what may 31st
and
now that was extended until what uh
august 31st
may sorry may 1st august 31st so
basically what they're arguing is we had
to get out on august 31st because 400
deadline to have gotten out several
months earlier well obviously they were
free to extend a deadline for as long as
they wanted
moreover the deadline was part of an
agreement with that had been reached for
the trump administration a weak one in
my opinion from us's point of view but
an agreement nonetheless uh that had
conditions in it
and the conditions had plainly not been
met to include the condition that that
the taliban would have reached an
agreement with the afghan government
negotiations on that never started
so the idea that they were under a
deadline of uh that the meaningful
deadline on on the first of may is
nonsense and everything is predicated on
that is therefore nonsense as well what
striking was the different numbers about
the people still on the ground the
people that the americans uh the green
card holders and then the sivs um these
are with the with the immigrant visas
special immigrant visas take a listen to
this q a with congressman zeldin
what is the number of americans who are
in afghanistan as of the last update you
received
the
congressman going back to this weekend
uh we had about a hundred american
citizens uh in contact with us who were
who seek to leave afghanistan those are
the those the americans we're working
with
do you have an exact number
i can't give you an exact number uh we
were talking about this a little bit
earlier it's really uh a snapshot at any
given moment because what happens is you
as of the last update you received as of
the last update it was about about 100.
okay how many green card holders
uh green card holders is something that
we don't track directly so what we've
done is we've solicited people if they
are green card holders to let us know
i think the uh the best estimates are
that there are several thousand green
card holders in afghanistan
billy went on to say they didn't have a
number states working on a number about
the special immigrant visas these are
the afghan allies who worked with the
u.s over two decades of war perhaps the
most
threatened by what's the situation on
the ground
the big thing is is that
we are hoping that the taliban agrees to
let them all out
yeah we're hoping we're relying on the
good will and good faith of the taliban
and as tony blinken put it some of them
the leadership now has challenging
backgrounds that's a euphemism for
murderers and torturers uh we're relying
on their goodwill look the question of
how many people how many siv holders how
many americans tears at the heart uh and
and and lord knows we want them all back
but what tears at the mind uh is the
celebration of terrorism that is going
on around the world
uh and you know this
the taliban's
hold will be strengthened uh by the fact
that terrorists all over the world will
descend on kabul and celebrate the
victory over the americans this is the
really frightening thing let's get our
guys out let's get the folks out who
helped us but goodness knows we are
facing a very very bad situation mike
mccall had it right
ranking member on the committee he said
this was betrayal and unconditional
surrender and
a scandal
herald secretary blinken as well as
democrats on the committee did point
back to the trump administration
numerous times in this testimony today
take a listen to a piece of that
when president biden took office in
january
he inherited an agreement that his
predecessor had reached with the taliban
to remove all remaining forces from
afghanistan by may 1st of this year
upon taking office
president biden immediately faced the
choice
between ending the war
or escalating it
had he not followed through on his
predecessor's commitment
attacks on our forces and those our
allies would have resumed
and the taliban's nationwide assaults on
afghanistan's major cities
would have commenced
we've talked about it a lot harold it
seems an interesting argument um your
thoughts on it
well first thanks for for having me on
look i think that point there he made is
one worth noting particularly for this
conversation
i would agree with brit hume that the
may 31st or may first or august 31st
state those were things that did not
have to be adhered to
maybe because the agreement called for
five thousand taliban prisoners to be
released it called for the taliban not
to attack u.s soldiers as long as we
adhere to the agreement so what i heard
secretary blinken saying there was that
if they didn't adhere to the agreement
that perhaps and maybe the taliban would
violate their part as well but let's be
clear they mishandled this exit this
could have been handled much better i'm
encouraged that democratic committees in
the congress democratic chairs of
committees are leading oversight of this
and are asking very probing and tough
and honest questions and i thought
secretary blinken probably should have
come down today to the house but i
thought he was very canned and honest
and frankly lengthy with some of his
answers
bret the politics of this and where this
goes we're in the moment here there are
people on the ground we're trying to get
out but the impact on this
administration this president from what
both sides say was was pretty hasty and
uh screwed up
yeah this is not a this is not a foreign
policy disaster that a lot of people
really disagree on there were sort of
faint attempts in that hearing today to
defend the administration in this or
that way but nobody's really arguing
this is well done or wisely done or or
in the end successful and to the extent
the administration continues to claim
that it is i think it's a stain on this
administration it is one that will
endure and my own view is that this has
placed joe biden in new light
in the eyes of most americans who you
know despite the fact that he had that
long career and was vice president they
didn't really know him that well this
was his first big one and he whipped on
it and i think it's and i think it's
left him damaged not just because of how
badly the the departures there from
there went but also because of how
poorly he handled it in the aftermath
one last thing a lot of the republican
questioning ended with one familiar
refrain and that is resign take a listen
i resigned those would be the two words
i'd like you're not going to resign
though you know that i know that
they're too arrogant what's something
realistic that you want to hear
uh i don't there's nothing else that i
want to hear from and it is so greatly
unfortunate the consequences and i
believe that you sir should resign that
would be leadership
you know bill i think congressman mast
is right that there's probably not a
chance that secretary blinken is going
to resign but there haven't been any
resignations or falling on swords in
this whole deal
no i don't think there will be the real
resignation should be the president
united states this was his game look
ryan crocker former ambassador to
afghanistan said to me in an interview
he said look trump made a mistake in
dealing with the taliban but biden owns
this a hundred percent this was his
decision and it's a disaster and a brief
briefly disagreement with my friend
harold ford rare but i don't think the
democrats were probing i think they were
really
getting behind joe joe biden attacking
republicans and trying to blame it on
donald trump that's a new card blame it
on donald trump
last thing harold do you think that the
trump administration would have done the
same thing here in this exit
look i don't know i hope not and we all
would wish they would not have but as we
talk about betrayal here for one moment
let me just remind everybody for 20
years we thought we had a partner in the
afghan government which turned out to be
on its best day on its best day wildly
incompetent and on its worst day both
incompetent
and corrupt so there's a lot of blame to
go here and i think that as we get
through some of these hearings and the
accountability begins to fall let's let
the chips fall where they may let's
learn from this era
and let's ensure and try to ensure going
forward that we don't make the same
mistakes
from covering the pentagon many military
leaders and administrations both kinds
republican and democrat said that that
afghan military and the government was
up to up to snuff at some point um okay
panel thank you we'll see you later in
the show hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else